ταλαβαίνεται πό τελεσματικά ν αλλάξουμε τώρα θέμα επόμενη μέρα για τη τέλνα κυριαγύδου που τη
βρίσκει στην κύπρο επιστροφή στην κύπρο είναι υβάσιμου και θα δούμε πραγματικά ξέρετε έχω πάντα
σε ότι έχω κάνει ως πέχρη σήμερα παραμένω από όλι τα στοχο προσηλωμένοι στε αυτό
που κάνου για μέένα δεν έχει ολοκληρωθεί η θυτία μου τητεία μου θα ολοκληρωθεί ότη
μέρα που θα αναλάβει είναι επιτροπη και είμαι πολύ συνδοποιημένι ότι πολλές φορές όλους μας
στις δουλειές μας θα αυτό που κάνουμε όταν πηγαίνει κάτι προς το τέλος που εί
να χαλαρώσεις και εκεί μπορεί να γίνουν λάθει δι ότι τα τά θέματα τρέχουν ιδικά
της συγείας σε κοσι ευτά κρατημέλη τρέχουν συνέχεια ι αυτό πρέπει μέχρη την τελευταία στιγμή
να παραμένω απόλιτα στοχο προσηλωμένοι όταν τελειώσω και επιστρέψειο κύπρο μετά θα πάρω το χρόνομο
να πάρω ς αποφάσεις μου για τα επόμένα δήματα η πολιτική τελειώνι για τη στελνα
κρια κήδουεδώ και πάρα πολλά χρόνια με στο χώρο της πολιτικής και βεβαίως θα παραμείνω
νεργός πολί της και θα σχολούμε μετάκινά και να είμαι οφέλειμη στον τόπο μου όπως
θημούν να πάντα επό εκεί και πέρα δεν έχω πάρει οποιες δήποτε αποφάσεις για το
ώς θα τεραστηριοποιηθο πραγματικά σας λέω ότι ακόμη γιαμένα τρέχει αυτό το χαρτοφυλάκιο δεν μπορούσα
να σας έχω εδώ και ναμι σας ρωτήσω τρεις σητίας στη βουλή αντιπρόεδρος δημορατικού συναγερμού
σε μερικές εβδομάες ολοκριώνεται θυτία σας αν επίτροπος σε μια περίοδο όπου και ο δημοκρατικός
συναγερμός δεν περνά καια την καλύτα